you
use please ensure mobile phones are on
silent or are switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
on the modern gov app for this meeting
please could members therefore ensure
they are logged in and ready to use the
app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation of the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if i can just turn and just turn off my
phone i do apologize but i was working
beforehand so i just need to make sure
that gets switched off
thank you
so introductions
officers attending the meeting today are
kay sanders licensing officer
katherine green licensing officer
nigel du our legal advisor and karen
sayer our governance officer so if i can
move to the agenda please
do we have any apologies
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor flatman councillor pratt
and councillor stringer
thank you very much
do we have any declarations of interests
by councillors
nope thank you
can we confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 16th of august
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
not that i can see
can i have a proposal and a second
please
counselor muller
and secondary please counselor brewster
thank you sorry
get rid of all these phones
so can we do an electronic vote please
to the minutes thank you
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking on the plus sign in the
top right of the agenda screen this vote
should now be open
so
that's six votes four chairs that's
carried thank you very much indeed
and i'll sign that at the end of the
meeting thank you
can we have any notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair thank you
questions by counsellors
and i'm received chair
thank you
so we now move on to the um first item
which is the mlr 21 6 gambling act 2005
statement of principles statutory
three-year revision
so can i ask kay to introduce the report
to us please thank you caisson
thank you chair
this report refers to policy setting
under the gambling act 2005 since
january 2007 local licensing authorities
have been responsible for functions
under the gambling act 2005 including
issuing of licenses and permits for
gambling and gaming premises and
associated matters
section 349 of the 2005 act requires
licensing authorities to prepare and
publish a statement
of the higher level principles it will
apply when dispensing its various
gambling functions the statement of
principles must by law be reviewed and
republished every three years or sooner
if so required
this year the authority is due to
revisit the statement
that has been in effect since january
2019
and this report seeks the approval of
the suit of a suitably revised version
in order that the statutory consultation
period may then commence on its content
the redrafted statement attaches
appendix a to this report contains
amendments from the 2019 published
version these revisions have been
collated
in a summary document and is attached to
this report as appendix b
the gambling commission revised national
guidance document to the license
authorities originally published in 2015
as amended in april 2021 has influenced
some of the revised draft content when
formulating the statement of principal's
revision
the legislation requires the licensing
authority to consult widely upon its
draft statement of principles document
with stakeholders before finalizing and
publishing the document in january 2022
as set by order the secretary of state
the sixth statement shall take effect
for a three-year period from 31st to
january 2022 through to the 31st of
january 2025.
the policy
that this policy that is before the
committee is for further consultation as
full council adopted the no casino
resolution on the 23rd of september
2021.
the duty to re-consult with the relevant
stakeholders in interested parties will
ensure that invented a statement of
principles is not open to a legal
challenge
at the recommend the recommendation to
council is
that the draft revision of a governing
act 2005 statement of principles
document attached as appendix a be
approved for consultation further that
the relevant officers proceed with the
commencement of the period of statutory
consultation in accordance with the
gabbling act 2005 legislation and
regulations
it is a statutory requirement to review
and re-adopt the council's gambling
policy
that concludes my summary
thank you very much for that um now i
wasn't here at the last time when um
we've we've possibly had some debate on
this before but is there any further
debate today it's all new to us and um
anybody like to enter into the debate
please
counselor mueller
thank you chair uh yes i've read through
the report and i'm sort of actually
quite happy with the report there are a
few um typos which you are aware of
which i've pointed out which i need to
be amended
but apart from that um uh taking into
consideration everything i i'm more than
happy with this and would be happy to
propose that we accept the
recommendation as put forward
thank you
thank you for that um do i have a second
of that before i come to cancer austin
councillor autumn um yes i'm more than
happy to second that um actually we did
have quite a good debate about whether
we should put forward um the proposal to
council about we do not wish to see
casinos
in the district
and for very good reasons
particularly about our concern about
people
addicted to gambling
and obviously the impact on children and
families
thank you
thank you i have a proposal and a second
would anybody like to speak to the
motion please
yes cancer
having read through it i have no
objections and i think it's a it's a
perfectly sensible um set of updates and
that uh i'm happy to support it
thank you very much indeed any further
comments
counselor brewster
thank you
right i'm i'll just pass do you want to
comment at all council rapping young or
not no need thank you i think everyone
else has said what i would like to say
so i think it's uh
clear that the changes are driven by the
previous resolutions we made about
casinos and it all sort of falls into
place so i'm happy to support right
well i wasn't here at the last um
meeting but i have read through the
documents and there were some updates
and things regarding um assistance dogs
and things like that in the new
documents so i think it's it's been well
thought through and so if we may now go
to the vote please
thank you chair
so the recommendation is that the draft
revision gambling act 2005 statement of
principles document attached as appendix
a to the report be approved for
consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the commencement of a
period of statutory consultation
in accordance with the gambling act 2005
legislation and regulations
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov app
and the item should now show in blue
thank you
a bit need a bit more rump
mine didn't to start with
do you want to take the vote um
i can take your vote verbally counsellor
counsellor
it's been very slow
do you want to log out and log back in
again perhaps i don't know
that's six votes for chair
thank you very much indeed that's
carried thank you for that thank you kay
so now um we ask uk to introduce the
report to the committee regarding the
new hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy thank you very
much indeed thank you chair
the purpose of the report is to report
back to the licensing and regulatory
committee the outcome of a full targeted
and public consultation which ran
between the 20th of august 2021 and the
16th of september 2021
in respect of the hackney carriage and
private hard vehicle licence and policy
for the controlled zone of mid-suffolk
district council
all options to be considered are
contained within the body of this report
on the 21st july 2020
the dft published its long-awaited
statutory standards um for taxi and
private hire licensing the new standards
brought in a raft of recommendations and
requirements which council must have
regard to in exercising their functions
under hackney carriage and private hard
vehicle licensing
the standards also replaced relevant
sections of the best practice guidance
issued by the dft in 2010
whether whether is a conflict between
the standards and best practice the
standards will take precedence the dft
will update the best practice guidance
for the councils in due course however
in the meantime it expects councils to
adopt its recommendations in the new
standards document
so that past failings of some licence
and regime regimes are never repeated
whilst the focus of the new statutory
standards and private hard vehicle
standards is on protecting children and
vulnerable adults all passengers will
benefit from the recommendations
contained in it
there is consensus that the common core
minimum standards are required to better
regulate the taxi in private hard
vehicles sector the overarching aim of
the statutory standards is public
protection
following the consultation exercise
mid-suffolk received 12 responses these
are attached to this report as appendix
b
officers responses to the comments from
consultees are attached to the risk
report as appendix c
for reason reference some common themes
have been color coded
from the responses received
the changes made are attached as
appendix d
the recommendations are
that the post consultation draft hackney
carriage and private hard vehicle
licence and policy attaches appendix
they'll be approved and that committee
makes a recommendation to cabinet that
the hackney carriage and private half
vehicle license and policy document be
adopted
and if i may chair could i give cancers
a brief update on
electric vehicles
the team attended a webinar on engaging
with the taxi industry on switching to
lower mission vehicles in september
the main point from this meeting was
that count the councils involved in the
meeting that were actually being
discussed were able to move forward with
evs and infrastructure because their
councils have employed individual
offices to deal with the transition to
evs
we had a meeting with the environment
strategy officer from suffolk county
council on the 13th of october there is
a community grant available for
infrastructure but this is um for the
public and the community not for
commercial and business
he referred to
a firm in norwich abc which have a total
fleet of evs and have installed
infrastructure at their own base this is
a very large company um i think from
right about 200 vehicles
um
this is not applicable to mid-south we
have two
two main officers in stone market
they're very small they don't have
anywhere to park their vehicles out
their officers to install their own
infrastructure
we do have an electric vehicle actually
being plated on monday
and if i have asked the gentleman to
keep a record of the costs um
customer comments etc where we can
charge it up for our you know for our um
information
and he's happy to do that there's no
plans for rapid charges in the district
which is what taxi drivers would require
um
a fast charger will probably take about
two hours to charge which is not
practical
um for for the trade
um and our nearest rapid charger is cop
dock
uh the cost of the electric vehicles is
repaid by the low running costs of the
server service charges and also
customer comments are positive it's a
smooth ride they're enjoying the
electric vehicles and they
ask if there's an electric vehicle
to be used because they prefer it
we're attending another webinar on the
21st of october this is relating to
charge point procurement for local
authorities um so we're hoping that may
help
in sourcing some income to
get some infrastructure for the drivers
for the taxi drivers
um the other other suffolk county county
and suffolk councils do not have ev in
their policies
um although they do mention and
they encourage it that they don't
actually have a policy on electric
vehicles
thank you chair
that's very helpful um i just must
apologize i i
jumped ahead of myself when i made a
comment earlier on uh we're now on to
this
thing so sorry my comment earlier is not
relevant to the previous
decision
just before we do go on we've all been
given
sight
of
the potential course
that we would be expecting um
the um it is a legal requirement isn't
it the course isn't part of the course
parts of the course are um and i got to
page 72 and i was absolutely fascinated
with what was in there
because i felt it sort of gave an
insight in what we should be doing with
our own vehicles you know checking them
um for winter and all sorts of things
like that so i don't wish to wish to
denigrate any of the remarks that people
have made here that they've said you
know they've been dealing with this for
all their life they know what they're
doing and and some people feel a little
bit
anxious about it and also people who are
managers they're saying well why should
we do it well if you're a manager you
should never ask somebody to do
something that you haven't done yourself
so i i hope you've all had a chance to
read
a little bit of the um potential course
that these drivers may operate on um and
obviously their comments relate to their
anxieties on it so i just thought i'd
i'd pass that out and one thing i have
suggested
um is maybe our officers might like to
go on the course if we've got enough
training funding so that they know who
they're talking to and what they're
talking about um but that would be
something for senior management to dip
in the pocket and help such a small team
um to attain that so um sorry i've sort
of rather jumped the gun and taken a bit
of
the starter of it
so um counselor otton you have your hand
up um
um
paragraph 11 about
obviously we'd like to encourage them to
convert to hybrid or electric vehicles
and therefore
who will be responsible for providing
any charging points is that down will
the council itself in order to encourage
them to do so
um and the other question is um on
mots
um
i'm i'm sure i'm not the only one who's
mo get caught out
because we don't get reminded now unless
you ask to be reminded about having an
mot
so i just wonder
i i couldn't see that in here under
obviously the maintenance of the
vehicles etcetera
okay as part of renewals or new
applications they have to provide a copy
of their mot
um obviously the onus is on them to
remember to reno we used to send out
letters um but that was when we were a
larger team we just don't
have the passage to send outlets to
every single
driver to remind them to get their mot
done
but we have sight of it at renewals and
for a new okay
i suppose the only
the only thing is
um
is that you can't actually tax a car
if you mot is not necessarily run out
but within 14 days of your car check so
i suppose they would then have to be
reminded by that yeah okay
thank you for that both uh council oh
sorry beg your pardon
charging
um as i was just saying that we are
researching that that doesn't we're not
aware of any funds from within the
council at the moment um but it's
something we're working on um as
discussed with cancer stringer last time
we're going to we're going to research
um we've got another meeting on the 21st
which
delves into procurement for local
authorities for the infrastructure so
hopefully that'll give us some hints and
tips on the way forward
and i think that's very positive that
which with us such a small team they
have been trying to look into that and
one suggestion i had um in our briefing
was maybe overall
um rather than leaving it to a small
team who aren't experienced in
procurement of things like that that
maybe the council might consider
um
you know that they can find a
procurement officer not us as members
but somebody needs to look into it for
planning and everything like that i'm
sure then you know as part of the
economic development team there must be
somebody in there
that is looking at that for you well we
need to link up with that but take it
forward definitely counselor
um did i see council epping young did
you have your hand up yes please thank
you
uh thank you chair um actually council
orton in her
final remarks did
pick up the point i was going to make
which is that you can't actually tax
your car if you don't have a valid mot
and clearly that's a process that
everyone has to go through
and also i think you know while i
appreciate some of the concerns that the
consultees have made about
the age of
and conditions of their vehicles
um
if you look at uh
the the ten trend of the the course that
they're being asked to undertake from a
practical standpoint
um that's something we all should be
doing to keep our vehicles in good
running order so
i'm not entirely sympathetic with those
views of theirs um if they're doing a
proper job um
and and actually i think you know we
have to see it in the round in terms of
their own safety as well as the safety
of the public that they're carrying
um i think with regard to
moving to electric vehicles i mean
obviously this is something that is a
challenge
for all of us
and the country as a whole and the
infrastructure uh for that is still
pretty nascent um and there are lots of
concerns about um the fact that the the
there's such a variety of them
um and and and i think government needs
to step in and and regulate and put a a
standard in uh you know
a bit like you can't go to the the
petrol station and put a a diesel
pump in your in in in your
petrol one or the other way around i
can't remember but anyway um but it
needs to be regularized so that you know
we have a standard infrastructures
charging system um and i know that for
example that we are putting some uh
charging points in some of our car parks
and i guess that's a a uh program that
needs to be accelerated if we're going
to encourage more and more people to uh
use electric vehicles and and obviously
we are completely aware that uh in in
less than 10 years time they're going to
stop selling
uh petrocarbon vehicles so
you know
i think that
the trade itself is moving in that
direction and and i travel around europe
a lot and i see many taxi firms only
operating um hybrid or electric vehicles
only so i think we
we can't kind of resist the tide if you
like
some very good points made there indeed
and
you know the car industry needs to get
together to make sure the plugs are the
same as you quite rightly point out so
very good points thank you anyone else
wishing to make comment
counselor
brewster yes thank you
sorry counselor is your microphone
yeah when i was reading through the
papers i thought we could we will get
some um adverse comments about the the
trade the training and the west office
college
um
stuff
um
i think that's
probably quite a short-sighted view
because
the benefit will come
to the
owners of the taxi company in terms of
of how
their drivers will be really up to this
up to speed you know rather than
i'm sure there are some
areas where they need to be that
and
yes the other thing about the electric
charging and yes that i mean obviously
there will be
some charging points
i also picked up on the
um
the
taxi
ranks and and certainly in stone market
there could be i think some larger areas
for them to park up when they need to
however
i think the team have done a fantastic
job they've obviously worked very hard
on this
with the amount of
explanations for for these items coming
through
and
i really do applaud them for for having
picked that up because once you start
reading those
you can start to see the benefits of
what this will bring forward for us
um
i have just one little point which is
which is a little bit of a typo actually
but
um on the appendix a the first
paragraph
i would like to see
on the second line district councils
and not district council
i think
that might have been confusing some of
the readers of it thinking that we were
already
yes
thank you
it's probably probably a little bit um
superfluous as everybody else has said
such very excellent things but i just
wanted to second councillor brewster's
uh comment about
the the really comprehensive and very
sensitive responses to the consultation
that i think that they
they're so helpful and so excellent so
thank you very much for that um and uh
and and also the taxi rank situation
we've got to keep that up in uppermost
in our minds those of us who have the
power to to do something about it um
must sort out more spaces i thought that
the the um
that pointing out that people aren't
being encouraged to use taxis to get to
supermarkets was a very sensible thing
that if you're going to decide to give
up your car the supermarket trip is one
of the things that you really do need um
some help with so so that was um good to
see thank you
yes i think all the points are very
relevant and i hope that the taxi
drivers themselves if they're watching
this now do appreciate um that uh i mean
i go through this as everybody else does
but our offices have given us such a
clear direction
um but not only that
um they have taken on board some of the
concerns and and altered one or two
things so it's not as if we're you know
just
it's not a tick exercise they've worked
extremely hard um and so um i do hope
they the the taxi drivers do think
and appreciate that we're not ignoring
them at all far from it
so um on that basis if no one else
wishes to say anything um
i would just say one yes please don't
just yes yes your comments the whole
team i've just said the whole team
worked on this um it's been a long piece
of work but it was
we're all involved
that's all i want to say thanks
thank you for that so i need a proposal
two hands go up counselor mullet and
then councillor evan young
councillor muller
so you're proposing it yeah
and
acting cancellation very happy to second
chair thank you very much in that case
then may we
move to
a vote please
thank you chair
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 as in the
paper
excuse me wrestling counselors if you
could please open the vote in the
modern.gov app and in the voting tab
this vote the vote for this item should
now show in blue
that's six four chair
it's carried
thank you very much indeed and thank you
everybody once again so that is carried
i'm now able to close the meeting thank
you very much indeed for all your
attendance and input thank you
[Music]